applications and because it's a workshop
on commercial capacity among I'm going
to talk about the application in the
communication complexity of decoding the
joint work with hurrah mati was a
postdoc I noticed and I went to Harvard
and now is in he's in Israel
masu antigen only read a few papers so
the mostly this work with Ronnie and
Lynn and then another one by Lee and
myself and the leads on the job market
for next year it's very good so
distribution Dion M beats is he wise
independent if any T bits are a uniform
gets a very basic notion that was around
since at least Carter and Backman and
thanks to a long line of research it's
known that these distributions full and
dissented I'm gonna go through in a
second several classes of interest so
for example that was a breakthrough and
comprehensive result by buzzy there
shows that with Pelagia to make T such
distributions luck random to DNF it was
a very nice result which was then
simplified but at swaram and extended by
Bremen to a zero and we know similar
things for the classes there is this
paper but with the colliculus the global
and J's volunteer billion which we show
it for parameter threshold functions of
degree one and in giving was excellent
while degree okay and there's more
adults by full here I mean that this
petition of any function in these
classes over the resolution this close
to this petition of a uniform okay so it
puts a lot of stuff but but there is a
one simple function which you all know
there is not fooled by these things
which is very thank you for so it does
not prepared
okay but you can tweak it a little bit B
and any food spare me
you can add some noise to D okay so what
I mean by noise so I'm going to denote
by capital and a noise vector of iid
bits and each each bit is 1 with the
probability 1 over 10 K or well rounded
and the main object of interest in this
talk is what you get by the bitwise XOR
of DNN did the present so it's the fact
the person actually foods parity okay so
let's say I mean by parity the parity on
any subset of the bits okay so it could
be one bit in which case you need a
which case usually it just folded by D
okay but it's if it's many bits actually
you need noise good so you actually need
both DNA and so if it's a parody on just
one bit
then noisy not sufficient okay we give
you error one over hundred just not good
enough if you want to get a rep
summation chef that she you need both D
and N and in all of our examples that
will be the case that really really the
combination of DNA which is importantly
he doesn't work with either D or n so
the interesting question is what is
fooled by D plus n okay and this
questioner goes back to a work by Diane
Peterson and M was rather revived in a
furnace worker by Gopalan make rang go
through our model but they think of it
in a different way they don't talk about
biobalance plus noise so thinking the
first work that discusses the things in
disturbance is this one so which model
is fooled by Bonnie variance plus noise
civil question
I want to stress that the special case
of other questions which are floating
around so for example we have seen in
the last workshop some very nice result
about boolean function severe and walks
okay and what they need for that is a
condition the free growth on the
functions so if you have a fully growth
it implies also the percent full sit
okay okay so what we shows the method
that I want to mention is something
which extend this simple pair defect in
which we spent a lot of time thinking
about starting at 3 years ago the
Simon's workshop here so this result
here so it's an extension on this fact
about parity for functions on Fri batali
functions ok so the setup is a kid as
you have K functions the Khazar a
founder now f1 f2 o FK little function l
bits okay and they're bonded even think
of it as just a minus 1 1 if you want
and then you look at the product of
these functions okay so the product
tester so it's a function f which now is
over L times K bits and the output is
bonded again so the value of f on a key
table will adjust the product subject so
f1 x1 times F torque so and so I want to
claim that this function here is fooled
by the presenter so you have some
required condition on T so T has to be
at least about L ok because if T is less
than L then just essentially just one
function can tell the distribution from
ok up to some correction with the noise
or it doesn't matter president is at
least 10 times L and then I claim it
forces so whatever bounder can we up for
here so what's the best possible error
bound that you that you grow for so this
thing could be a parity on P plus 1 bits
what would be the error in decades
[Music]
OBD error fish aversion give us one bit
so they could do nothing for you so you
just be just then also would be
exponentially smaller in T and that's
what you get okay so the error here is
this this thing is tight just because
apparently you can write the parity as a
product of these functions make sense
and this thing is tied to big awesome
so in particular I don't have any
dependence on K so who proved this bound
so there was this period by Hannity
Lingala which showed something which is
good but only unfortunately when a K is
more spirit took us a global effort then
there is another paper by with three in
which we have large K but the bound of
Porter is not the good but it's a worse
bound and then there is a very nice
paper by forcing heli which I think
would just in this last stock Fox anyway
just give up on line in which they take
they are a medallion viola and they
modified a little bit in a very nice way
and essentially get this bound get
something a little bit worse the K it's
not written in there but implies a bound
form a K times 2 to the minus Omega T so
they still have dependence on K but you
can just use a simple idea from me and B
Allah to remove it so if you combine
this and that you will get this bound
here
so I'll tell you again bitter what's
what's the roof of that
well someone years in the roof before
that I want something about applications
these things had shipped several
applications so once their obligations
in the aerosol pseudo randomness I
mention in this question with fully a
growth but basically you can use the
disturb results to get pseudonyms not
for a friendship programs focusing can
leave paper essentially matches the so
nice honest this Roxanna generator in
which Chickenfoot branch improved in a
fixed order they can essentially do the
same thing in arbitrary order which is
very nice and the indifferent threat
there is also a governess paper online
by Mecca wrangled town in which they
they do random jail for with three
branching programs they also used ideas
from these papers some advances is taken
from here in addition to many other
things ok so but today I wanted to
stress this consequence for
communication complexity there seem to
be some more applications coming out ok
so let's move to communication
complexity
so the setting is dead of error
correcting codes
very something with a question for you
what's harder encoding or decoding
or you think they're coding can you move
it so it seems like de Koning is a drag
can you prove it anyone say one modeling
which you can prove that that decoding
is out there turn encoding are annoyed
can you encode the innate zero no could
you just flip a bit and then you have a
distance can you decode as far as I know
it's open no no if you can be called in
h0
okay so somehow on the edge from that
tree proving a result along this line so
I'm gonna give you a setting in which
the decoding is harder can the
communication of Blackstreet setting and
the communication complexity over some
streaming questions were asked to ready
but they couldn't say anything more
about the calling than encoding which
they both are somewhat harder for
streaming or things like that
okay so what's the setup all right so
here's our setup so for simplicity I'm
just gonna say things for it Solomon
codes so I have a reed-solomon code
or some alphabet fq block length n so
for this result I will need to
generalize this to not two bits but two
arbitrary alphabets and I'm not Sony
generation in which the rates of the
error is taking into account which is
not written here but it's follows along
the same lines with some code so let's
say this thing has dimension
[Music]
let's say I'm working so kidnapper on
the let's say K is like hundred so as I
mentioned m / 108 come over you can't
she essentially remove this constant let
me just pretend here okay
so then there is a so there is a
received word with some number e of
errors so the warrior and this wardr now
split among k parties should split among
KK parties
okay so splitting just a number in hand
okay so party I just know this part you
just know that and and so on and this
part is communicate decode one message
symbol
okay so this up here and you want to
know how much they have to come to
communicate for that just because one
symbol okay and the theorem is that the
communication is a de piel de because
I'm going to ignore some logs of e so
the amount of communication is just the
number of errors errors and this thing
is tight so good so let me think of K is
just some fixed constants and so let's
say K is like a million then of course
so for this to make sense it has to be
horrible at all so actually it can't
can't become linear with M so let's say
just is like you know between zero and
one over a billion so you may actually
generalize this to smaller K but I'm
just writing all the case being a
constant for now but okay so actually to
maybe to balance the your questions
there's no there's no relationship so
the boundary is just in terms of me I
think I think he he told snout this
Forbes and can result II he got even for
for bad for EM for EM freedom for a very
large K you get chicken so the upper
bound is just it's a very simple thing
and the lower bound come from two such
let me give you the proof to sketch of
this that you can see how I use that
theorem actually before that so just a
note that so if you just want to compute
one symbol of the encoding it would just
be constant communication
okay so in this sense if you find it
satisfactory it shows that the decoding
is more complicated the proof sketch
immune contest catch it show you how the
pieces together but so a way which
searches some symbols are very easy to
decode so what I mean here is that there
exist actually for most symbols it would
be it would be really difficult or
forgiving symbol so so you know skeleton
sorry if you fix a message symbol okay
so for most symbols you you have just
decreased the dimension by one so you
have a you know 10 M over K minus 1
reed-solomon code okay for some symbol
suffix maybe not oh so such codes so
it's known that you know a uniform code
word is you know this much independent
this thing this is my value of t it's
not much event this is just because you
know a random line bush in two points of
the same probability so that means that
if you now think of the noise has been
uniform at the parties won't be able to
distinguish a uniform cold water from
from this thing and noise and this thing
called for any possible way in which I
could have fix it's much the same but
when she went alleged demo information
or the messages humorous make sense I'm
fooling communication protocols oh yes
sorry Shippuden line so yes so you know
a party iki party protocol you know is a
union of products so the number of the
number of products or products mean of
tests of this type so the number of
products would be its expansion
denominator so you do need to prune
error which depends on the on the error
rate to get this bound which it's an
extension of that yeah that's how you
get lower bound okay
okay this is T bits of communication are
needed so this bond has to be
generalized with with the arrow Q
doesn't with the error rate so you know
it's the ribbon has to be disarray or
abandoned on the noise rate so it would
be
okay and so I show you the proof of this
theorem now and actually I wanted to
show you this Forbes and Kelly extension
but then even though it's very simple
somehow it's there is it's not went to
in intuitive for me to explain it in to
mute so I'm gonna go back to the fewest
warrant and tell you some ideas of how
you can actually so he was a the basic
idea in the Prasad but wait the Pierce
was already is sufficient to get this
bound for coats for say work cosine K or
even a bit larger so
okay so here's between you let's let's
look at in the case of K equals 3 for
the simplicity so we're looking at F 1 F
2 F 3 and the the basic idea is this so
let me write f 3 as f 3h plus f 3l so
they I should say at the beginning that
you know the basic idea just like with
parodies that you know the noise will
fall so we're going to use some free
analysis and the noise will for the -
coefficients and the bonaventure will
fold the small Fourier coefficients from
rising is said somehow is not so
straightforward so here is the way which
you can do it so and you're going to
decompose the F 3 in the sum of 3 h and
f 2l + f 3h you know has the high for
the coefficients high for the positions
f 3l has the low and once if I do this
and apply get here then I get that so
this is my F my F now becomes F 1 times
F 2 times f 3h plus F 1 F 2 F 3 L okay
and now I'm gonna it was natural to us
and now let's keep doing that okay I'm
just gonna do this thing again here I'll
tell you second why so you can do that
so I'm gonna keep keep this one F 2 F 3
H then I'm gonna have this thing I'm
gonna have 1 F - sorry F 1 F 2 h f 3l
and then I'm going to have F 1 F 2 well
guess what just decompose F 2 and then
I'm going I'm going to repeat the
process here so on
here is this end open up F so what you
get here is f1 h f2 l f 3l plus f1 L f12
f 3l this is just the product of lo
Fourier coefficients so you know if the
threshold that you picked here is T over
3 and your key was in balance and this
thing is just for the buggy guess that
each of these factors is fooled by the
plus n actually for this thing so you
need both the D and n let me just show
you for you in a minute how you can do
that
and some part of the complication is
that for us is that f3 alumina be bonded
it's something question of a bonding
function but it may not be bonded but it
doesn't matter so you're looking at the
expectation of let's say let me do one
terminal let me just - I'm just which 1i
f 1 inch so I mean call these things
here G I'm looking the expectation of 1h
and then this is the specification over
D plus M okay so the noise is a uniform
test right so I can bring it inside so I
have expectation over D on the
expectation of the noise of F 1 H this
is the part of the which belongs to F 1
so the 1 plus and then times the
expectation over and then just inside
the noise now you know you can do
cauchy-schwarz and to decouple these two
things so you will get the expectation
of B of this petition over N square f 1h
d plus m and some other stuff yes
petition over do these things here now
Gia's a clock degree so even if you
square it is still gonna blow degree
it's gonna be twice the degree of set
the various editing is small just by D
okay so I'm gonna I'm not gonna
I'm not going to worry about this okay
so maybe it's not clear anyway I'm going
to ignore that term so now essentially
just because this thing as high for the
coefficients of the annoys part that
will fall it so D is used for because it
takes squared
takes care of the square here small so
the error here will be the size of the
threshold that you
yes yes oh yes watch the the food is
good so so here fooling mean that you
you will get the what you wanted 0 for
the coefficient and then the answer
would be guess more so the Forbes in
college she is a very thin idea they
began they they decompose the function
in in things like this with a high
frequency and low frequency art again
they use the exactly this reasoning but
while in our case seemed that every
decomposition it was a little bit in
degree so you couldn't repeat these
things more than the time civilians
thing together one somehow they have a
different way of group in Africa
efficient which allows them to repeat
humor often
[Applause]
that's a fantastic question to the last
X here summer life thinking about this
and what's the function that's not
fooled by D plus M I spent like enormous
Ando time on did not know that it means
anything but still I spent it so we
don't know so the best that we we can
show so for example for for long si
circuits you can do actually it's not
food you will need even prototype pounds
you actually give me the exponential
parameters to forums circuit then you
push this to like NC to but team and
showing that NC one or like this is zero
so just to be concrete you know for
example can you full you know does order
of log n why is independence plus noise
X is zero
I spent a lot of time on this but I
don't know I do a simple function which
I know that requires
superpolynomial parameters in sometimes
Eliza I believe in NC - oh yeah so yes
so one reason why thank you
what is the why when Teresa so it's just
it's decoding right so if you can give
me a code that that you can decode yeah
thank you - imagine it if you give me a
code that you can decode then when you
break this and you can decode the Reed
Solomon codes in Nancy - I don't know
how - because it's on codes in NC one if
anyone knows I will be very happy
I think and to do so it just inverting
good system okay I don't know right so
it's essentially it's in world class
like that or something I don't know how
to do so I don't know how to do I'll do
it in SF substantially global classes we
ventured seemed to me he does to be a
code of do distance so do and do that
because of bullying but over binary so
sorry okay so so okay that's very
interesting yourself actually I look at
those aberrant yeah
poor law because I think it's like log
it's not it's fantastic question so we
know that which is not obvious so we
have a result which says that you you do
need the Omega claw game for DNF so it's
not complete opposite thing you'll need
to mega log n for a DNF but I don't know
if you need more than that
Omega log n like maybe order log n plus
noise false a DNF I think you're not for
anyone your is the same
oh it sees I'm not doing anything fancy
to adjust that so it's like
communication is rectangles right so a
product so think of this as a rectangle
just think with like 0 1 this is the
characteristic function of the K
dimensional rectangle this is number in
the hand so so for to play for K goes to
is is that this thing is just rectangles
4k would 3 becomes cubes and so on
this thingie suggests the grantee sztyc
function of a rectangle four cables -
and you can write any protocol just
summing over transcript sieve analysis
so that that's what I'm doing
square brackets or here oh yeah I don't
know so you need this so I'm doing this
so yeah for communication complexity you
would just need Cadiz yes your justice
but in fact the only stuff you get you
to do all this over c1 which has some
context is for the subtest I don't just
need to see it through map for
communication
more questions
[Applause]